how to de-stress as an entrepreneur so i
got a great question for one of my
youtube viewers
love you guys marilyn who wrote in to
say hi evan can you make a video about
taking a day off or just turning it off
as an entrepreneur we're always working
both mind and body how do you destress
and detoxify yourself
from all these buildups do you turn off
your phone no emails
put up a do a disturb sign do you
believe in holistic cleansing
just wondering thank you thank you for
the great question
and running the business is not easy
right this isn't easy whoever said this
is going to be a walk in the park
they're kidding themselves this is this
is the hardest thing you're ever going
to do in your life
if you're pouring your heart into it and
you're facing rejection you're not
seeing the momentum
this is hard and you are gonna get
stressed out and
and just battling through and staying
motivated helps but i'm gonna give you
my three
suggestions to help you de-stress
maybe detoxify but help you build a
better business one that you're proud of
and one that you can continue on running
number one is eliminate distractions you
mentioned do i turn off my email do i
turn off my phone
i don't have a phone i don't use a cell
phone number
i don't check my email during the day i
don't check my
social media accounts you know i have
designated times for everything
it's really important if you want to
stay as stress-free as possible as an
entrepreneur
to have dedicated times of focused work
i prefer 90 minute chunks and i say in
this 90 minutes i'm going to focus on
this and only this
and every time you get distracted you
lose your focus and then to get back
into where you were
was it's hard right you lose your
momentum and it stresses you out because
you want to get this thing done
it's like you keep getting interrupted
and you can't make any progress
i remember last night i got an idea i
wanted to i wanted to interview howard
schultz who's the founder of
starbucks as the chairman of starbucks
from my book
and uh so i started writing him an email
i started writing
and and my wife nina uh
says hey evan can you come look at the
freezer and like ah you know let me
finish
let me finish uh writing this note
and and i'll be right there and then i'm
still writing i'm so right and she
thought i'd finish i said hey can you
come look at the freezer i'm like oh
fine fine i'll come look at the freezer
and there's these icicles that were
forming or whatever
and then i got frustrated and then i
went back and i looked at my email like
i totally forgot what i was doing
and i had to get back in the zone and
like i just wanted to finish
and so that happens to a lot of people
all the time you keep getting
interrupted with people knocking at your
door or calling or emailing you
and that you're always in reactive mode
instead of
chunking out times blocking it off and
saying this is what i'm going to work on
for this 90 minutes so that's what i do
90-minute chunks 15-minute breaks in
between to let your brain
you know de-stress a little bit and
shift gears and just not look at the
computer or whatever you're doing
and then into your next 90-minute chunk
and don't let people
walk all over your time you've got to
set up limits and say
this is what i'm doing nobody bugged me
and and
you know i don't check my phone or email
any of that stuff so you got to turn all
that stuff off
number two is design a better business
design a better
business i hate the idea of
i'm gonna work so hard on my business
and and stress myself out so much and
then just
take a break from it all and build up
the
the the fortitude to go off and do it
all again
and invest all this time and then have
to go take another vacation i think your
business
you are you're not working with somebody
else right this is your business you
could design
whatever you want to do you get to
create the world that you want to create
so design a world that supports you i
don't think you have to be all stressed
out
and then take a break from it all your
business should be designed
in a way that you get energy from it it
shouldn't be an energy stealer
the things that you do in your company
should lift you up
and not super stress you out all the
time i make these videos
not because somebody told me to do
videos not because it's a smart
business thing to do but i love it like
i love being able to answer questions i
love being able to reach people
your comments mean the world to me they
make my morning every day
when i'm eating my lentils and checking
out my computer that's the first thing i
look at because
it gives me energy you guys fueled me to
do more and to be better
and if there was something that kept
stealing my energy kept stressing me out
i would eliminate it
gone like that it does not need to be in
my life
and i'll focus on something else that
gives me energy so design your business
in a way that supports you and feeds you
instead of drains you
and number three is follow your flow
as much as i have my day scheduled and i
have my 90 minute chunks at a time
and you know wednesday is my video day
so i'm sitting here recording
all of these videos i like to stay in
flow
as much as possible try to get the flow
and listen to your body and having
an awareness over what you're feeling
right now
and how it's translated into your work
and so what i mean by that is sometimes
you're working on something and you're
feeling it and you're in the flow and
just um awesome stuff is being cranked
out
and you know that you're creating great
work and then other times it feels like
a struggle
you know like ah like you can't get in
the zone and the
quality you know is suffering to force
that
doesn't work like you know you're not
going to get great results from it so
stop and go do something else so when
i'm making these videos
you know i do two videos every day so
like 14 videos a week
are coming out and i got to sit down and
record these things and answer your
questions and do all this stuff
and some wednesdays i sit down and and i
can pump out 20 videos and it's like
boom i'm on fire
answering questions you know i had a
great session with jenny before i'm
drinking my smoothies whatever it is and
and i am just killing it and other
wednesdays i feel like i'm not in my
rhythm yet and i'm
you know just not hitting it and so i'll
stop
early maybe i'll do five videos or maybe
i get to
my tenth video and and i've poured
everything into it it's like you know
what
that's it i have no more left there is
nothing left here
to create another video i feel like my
next one won't be good so i'm going to
stop
and so it's designing the business back
to number two designing the business
where i don't need to have
14 videos every single week i can create
more one week and less the next week
and so on so i've designed it to support
me and i can stay in my flow
so remember if you want to de-stress as
an entrepreneur number one eliminate
distractions number two
design a better business and number
three follow your flow
believe for those who watching if you
liked the video you want to see more
just like it you can click on the
subscribe button to subscribe to the
channel
thank you so much for watching and i'll
see you soon
you